everybody welcome to the Rubin report
I'm the Muslim Brotherhood's favorite
comedian dave rubin and we've got two
great guests returning champ Gina grads
second time very happy to have her and
one of my favorite comedians who I have
been harassing endlessly on the Twitter
Andy Kindler who we even went to the
same College Binghamton University I've
ever heard of it it's a great clown
college up in upstate New York and all
right we got a lot to get to so here we
go so Egypt it changes every moment it
will probably change by the time I
finish this sentence but so there's a
lot going on I'll start at the beginning
you know the Hebrews built the pyramids
and then Moses got them out blah blah
blah then they had 30 years of Mubarak
and the military running then they had a
democratic election Muslim Brotherhood
jumped in and more seed they did not do
anything good actually turn things for
the worse then we had a coup even though
we don't call it a coup now the military
is in charge again and nobody's happy
because they're killing people left and
right and the Muslim Brotherhood's in it
and are they terrorists or what's going
on let's watch a little video tape it
and see how actually how bad things
so we're seeing tons of that stuff look
back I didn't look armed was he part of
the Muslim Brotherhood are they
terrorists the military's doing this
stuff we're funding the military is all
of this stuff just over the top like we
can't even fathom this as Americans to
really have a real decent discussion
about it and we don't have any sense of
history history in this country also we
don't have I don't have a good visual
thing because I didn't know what was
going on there right I thought it was a
rugby game I had no idea so I apologize
to the families to everyone's phone but
the thing is we have no sense of history
here and we have the we've been
controlled by the right wing for so long
so everything is filtered through that
lens so it's like it was up to the right
wing that wouldn't be Muslims you know
right everybody would be into Christian
education camps so it's very very hard
to figure out the thing that bothers me
is is all these pundits not eugenia but
most of these pundits are constantly
they want obama no matter what happens
it's his fault why doesn't he make a
decision and that's what dry and that's
what drives me nuts because it's such a
difficult thing there's only so much
that we can do in that area yeah there
is only so much we can do and I agree if
the pundits are not helping because
everybody just picks their side and
sticks to it no matter what but is there
a way to have like a really decent
discussion about this understanding a
little history and context and all that
um I'd like to I'd like that by saying I
have no idea mmm and then how we're
doing the show right you're doing at
target audience that's the thing because
I consider myself pretty well informed
you know my only two presets in the car
FM and AM top radio and I listen to this
stuff all day and I still don't
understand it so we're taking it like a
little snippet of what's going on now
and widening it out and saying okay you
guys what do you think but most people
don't even understand how we got to this
point so I don't know you know and I'm
gonna speak as the complete lay person
and say I still don't understand forgive
me why morsi was ousted if he was
supposedly voted in democratically i'm
confused right i'm super [ __ ]
confused
the language is what bothers me no but
that's not the point is is that he was
supposed to uh bring the country
together but the thing is he I think he
was already cracking down on various
rights and was the imprisoning people
you take it away dude he was he was
imprisoning people he was not giving any
of the freedoms that they had gotten rid
of mubarak for and he was democratic
elected aren't we supposed to always
defend democracy because we didn't in
this case right well I think we're
supposed to do that I think which was do
the best that we can under the
circumstances we're hated worldwide you
know a lot of people don't even know
that we overthrew the guy who was in
Iran in nineteen human he was elected we
said CIA say oh well it came at this
week but we've known about it forever
right and so it's then when 1979 comes
along Ted Koppel makes a living out of
going day 72 that you were born then day
43 so it's also all of our anger is
focused on certain things and we don't
see the big picture I think we just try
to do the best that we can and I don't
like you know it seems like too many
people got killed I mean anybody getting
killed is horrible but you know the more
see people are also attacking a
Christian churches and and there's a
part of there's an element there that
wants to cause revolutionary so
something like sixty churches were
burned why doesn't the Pope say anything
about that that's what I keep thinking
is weird the Pope is always up in
everybody's bedroom and wants to know
what everybody's doing was in my bedroom
last night and when I sang my fill in
the blank right yeah but why doesn't it
really why does the Pope jump in on this
I find it very bizarre they're they're
killing Christians and they're
destroying churches Pope no quiet I I
don't get this Pope I I think he's
interesting and everyone said like oh
he's the Francis pope and he's the
charitable on and he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about all the whatever all this stuff
but is he is he the Obama hopes well you
know I know he just kinda wants everyone
to be happy doesn't want to really
ruffle any feathers he's actually made
some nice comment about gays which is
bizarre for a home maybe
maybe he just kind of wants to stay out
of it he's a new PO but i don't know i
i'm not a people person i like to do
that joke I'm not normally a people
person no but are there Coptic
Christians yeah so is that not under his
Oh everybody should say doesn't matter
what the church is he comes that's not
my brand I can't comment right experts
here exact right exactly we got three
Jews oh maybe he feels like he can't
maybe he feels I just want to flame on
either side the Pope right he do he does
like to flame but not maybe in this
particular part of the world but alright
so final question of this are we just
screwed one way or another there we look
we give the money they use the weapons
to turn against their people we don't
give the money and then more radical
people come in so one way or another is
this just typical like America we just
get in everybody's business and then
everyone hates us and we leave no better
they're gonna hate it I think I think
you're right what you said that we're
damned if we do and damned if we don't
if we don't get involved people are
outraged that we don't care if we get
involved it's America comes in and
thinks that they can get in everybody's
business and fix everything but they
just make it worse so I I don't I thing
cuz we can't make things better because
first of all i am a i'm an obama tarian
i am in the tank for obama I have an
Obama outfit at home i love it i think
i've been around longer than you guys
and longer than the country and I think
he's the greatest he's the best
president we've had in my lifetime it is
is he perfect i don't like some of the
things in education so I feel like he I
think that he has tried to turn around
the perception of America and I think
he's gonna but I think he's in a tough
situation and I'm but I'm optimistic I
hope in general things will move better
in the world that was a big ship to
steer I mean you know people say like
well it's not perfect well you know it's
it takes a while to 180 better